[Music]
they'll be there by attending nothing
jay-z's performing Beyonce and jay-z
will be front row and we might be in for
a few no-shows pursued Song of the Year
nominees Luis FONSI and daddy yankee
will performed Esposito but the Biebs
he wasn't announced as a performer
there's no seat for him and as of
yesterday Justin was just chilling in LA
grabbing lunch with his dad nominee
Taylor's also not expected remember look
what you made me do was snubbed but this
Idol will be
nominee Kelly Clarkson was beaming at
last night's star-studded Warner Music
Group three Grammys party with bee
magazine where Bruno Mars collaborator
first-time nominee cardi B arrived in
style then quick changed to perform
showing a lot of skin and a ton of
enthusiasm not just about performing her
hit with Bruno Sunday what I'm most
excited to see is just like me hopefully
we did in a war like what I was like
that's what I think about to be honest I
don't think about nobody else got me
[Applause]
birthday girl Alicia Keys already
celebrating the now 37 year old and
hubby Swizz Beatz were honored by the
Recording Academy last night on Sunday
they'll join others wearing white roses
to support time's up we're in support of
all things that need to change changes
[Music]
you